when it comes down to strategy sessions
there's two different kinds of strategy
sessions one of them is just on the cup
we go into board and we grab a marker we
start writing we say what we're going to
do next that could be on a day to day
basis weekly basis the kind of strategy
session I want to talk about here is the
one I do once every year and I've been
doing this as 2005 2006 where you go
away with certain group of people with a
specific outcome on what to do for the
following year
[Music]
you know so many people want to wing
themselves into an incredible year and
all of a sudden my gosh this thing is
gonna start working out for me and it
doesn't the reason why I'm sharing this
with you is because you're talking to a
master winger doing everything about my
business until 2005 2006 I decided every
single year during December I'm gonna
get away and I called it mastermind
Alliance this is a strategy session a
retreat where we get together with our
core leaders this becomes my entire
emphasis of leadership development
casting my next innovative campaign
uniting the entire team together getting
a kind of a pulse on where everybody is
that I get to look at their eyeballs
together and then if we unite you feel I
want to unite if we unite I already know
we're gonna start the next year on a
strong strong momentum simply because we
had that strategy session to get in the
month of December so now if you're
watching this and Pat I don't want to do
it in December I want to do in September
July January February whatever season it
is you're watching and no matter what it
is you can kick it up on any month I'm
just telling you I did it in December in
this video I'm gonna share with you the
12 things that I did every single year
going into these strategy sessions
number one so the first thing you got to
keep in mind is this is not a meeting to
invite everybody because we're gonna get
together we're gonna have fun sucker
shindig oh my gosh we're gonna do all
this other great things together this is
a very serious meaning for me with a
sprinkle of fun because everybody needs
to have a little bit of fun for their
mind to be opened up so they're willing
to take things from you but I don't
invite everybody the people that get
invited to this meaning are leaders I
even announced what needs to be taking
place way in advance as a criteria for
folks to want to be part of this meaning
this allows me to realize who really
wants to be there by doubling down on
their effort what happens when you do
this is those who double
their efforts to be there are coming
there with a specific outcome of
bringing value to the meeting and those
who you invite to don't take it for what
it's worth the value of it they kind of
come an entitled feeling like oh my gosh
you know he has to me you like pulling
ideas out of them I like to have some
kind of a fight of people wanting to get
into the strategy session so she the
ones that I do once a year number two so
here's the next thing that I do
everybody that comes you have an
assignment here's what the assignment
could be one of the assignments is a
book you got to reach I need you to read
this book write a paper on it send it to
me before this meeting in order to for
you to get into this meaning and
literally we get papers or if you don't
bring the paper and type that not
written out type that three paragraphs
that's your ticket you won't be able to
get in I'll send them case studies to
study I'll send them a video to study a
paper to study an article to study I'll
ask them and a set of 20 questions 30
questions to answer
so they come prepared ideas to bring but
all of those things are assignments they
get before they come to the mastermind
session that we do once year number
three by the way this is not something
you do at your office this has to be at
a place that is three hours away and the
reason why it's three hours or more it's
because if it's an hour away people will
go there come back and sleep at home I
don't want them to sleep at home
I want you to sleep off-site preferably
if I run a big house say ten bedroom 15
bedroom I can have them sleep out the
house but if not they'll stay at a hotel
and all of us will stay out of hotel and
we'll wake up in the morning and work on
something to get if he can rent out a
house where you're all together it's
even better because this is not a suit
meeting this isn't a business attire
meaning this is a loose meeting for us
to roll up our sleeves and get down and
dirty and start coming up with some
ideas so it can't be at your office
minimum three hours away from your
office number four so the next thing I
do is when I prepare for meeting like
this is I ask myself what is my outcome
of this meeting meaning if I had a
perfect meeting what is a perfect
meeting look like for every leader that
I'm inviting to this meeting I make a
note for every single teammate that's
being invited on what I would like to
see them make a shift or an adjustment
on and what things we can come together
with to be on the same page and if I can
get there even if I get close to it
that's a victory so it's for you you're
watching this you got to sit down and
get very clear about what your outcome
of this meeting is
number five so one of the things you got
to do when your leaders come there's you
got to give them a lot of data and stats
here's why I'm all about data and stats
predictive analytics trends because I'm
able to sit down and know what region
what state what office what group
whatever it is what leadership team what
department is doing it right and who's
not and what these guys need to improve
in and what these guys are doing right
that they can share with the rest of us
maybe it's an accountability system
maybe it's a certain reporting thing
they're doing maybe it's a certain way
they're communicating with one another
but whatever it is I love data stats to
be able to study our next trends based
on what we're looking at here we are
projected to have this kind of a year
next year number six
simplicity is key with meetings like
this and the one word that I've been
talking about for years every time I do
these meetings is the word read it makes
me what I mean by read everything to me
is read re-engage rekindle re remind
re-energize resell division re
everything is Reno you may say but Pat
I've been doing that for the last 12
months I've been doing that for the last
five years free never gets old every
single year
John wood would get with his players and
he would say this is how you put your
socks on Lombardi would say this is a
football the basics the fundamentals the
re reminders what we stand for as a
company what the vision is what we're
going after where we're gonna be one day
five ten years from now that sets the
mood at the beginning then here's what
we got improved number seven so remember
this nobody knows your business your
company or organization whatever team
you're leading better than your nobody
does so you know the flaws you know your
flaws you know certain conflicts you
know certain things that are not aligned
together so sometimes it makes sense to
bring in outside consulting and outside
author you're paying five thousand
dollars three thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars twenty whatever it is
for them to come and speak for an hour
maybe you address a certain topic that
is a part of your outcome we're having
conflicts but how do we address
conflicts together we don't like
accountability whereas accountability is
so important right and they'll address
those issues they'll go through
questions and if you do it right with
the speaker beforehand they're gonna
validate the point that you're trying to
make to your organization number eight
so one of the things we do at these
meetings is there's a certain point
where I get everybody aside and we're
going to and we watch a movie - you
or a documentary together one time we
had Senna we watch in Puerto Verta I
rented to two big waterfront properties
and we sat there watch Senna because I
wanted the message of what it is for a
person that wants to find out what their
best looks like like the spirit of
competition
another time I had the team come
together and we watch a documentary
about sting the singer how 9/11 happened
and he wanted to perform with a bunch of
musicians at his house and how they
address this conflict together he was
heartbroken he's crying I don't want to
perform when a guy were performing with
his cheb mama Jeb mom is from the Middle
East I don't know if that and
everybody's talking to each other and
they finally perform it's the most
ridiculous concert they put together
showing the fact that look not
everything's gonna go your way but if we
come together we can do it we did 85
Bears one time I found so many so many
movies another time I didn't meet the
trumps and the reason why they meet the
Trump's is to get people to realize luck
forget about who Trump is what is your
legacy go back to his grandfather look
what his grandfather did his grandfather
set the tone properly that eventually
his grandson becomes a president so
there's certain things every time
there's a message I want to get across
documentaries and the right movie can
completely shift your entire team from
not being on the same page both to being
on the same page together two hours
later number nine at the beginning of
the meeting if you can figure out a way
to recognize certain one your team
members and leaders it will absolutely
increase morale and by the way
recognition doesn't need to be these you
know plaques and all this other stuff
you're doing it could be fun stuff I
mean we've given away Mickey Mouse toys
we've given AI so many different fun
things because it's fun that we talk
I've given away fish how you going
fishing we don't so many different
random things but it completely changes
morale and fun and laughter and all this
other stuff so if you can figure out a
way to make certain people in that group
feel special go ahead and do it number
10 here's one thing I will tell you that
it's unorthodox and some books will tell
you oh don't do it this way but here's
how I did it over the years we had a
start time but we don't have an end time
let me explain to what I mean by this we
literally have a start time we will
start 9:00 a.m. sharp and we'll do a
lunch we'll do breakfast we'll do all
this other stuff but we may finish at
one o'clock in the morning well we may
finish at two o'clock in the morning one
time we had a meeting we did at Yucca
Valley at this castle I rented
and we were dressed like medieval time
dresses that we had and we went to seven
o'clock in the morning but the following
month we had the greatest month we ever
had in the history of our organization
so start I'm fine and time any time
number 11 so there's a part of this
meaning that's bipolar and let me
explain to what I mean by this I am very
serious at these meetings when I tell
you very serious I'm very serious we're
gonna get a lot of stuff done but at the
same time we're gonna have fun as well
and when I tell you fun we'll do pranks
random pranks like we'll say your phone
cannot go off if your phone goes off
you're 100 dollars or ten dollars or
you'll be asked to leave
we will go plant a phone under the most
innocent person in the room and we'll
have somebody call them and the phone
goes off and everybody's in on the act
except the person where the phone goes
up so what's wrong with you I'm telling
you my phone's not going up and it will
make that footage and we'll have some
fun with this so you got to add some
kind of an element of fun and pranks to
it because again a group energy goes up
they're gonna come back and remember
those specific moments and the fun times
we had and they're gonna want to go to
the next one you do again whatever that
following you're maybe and number twelve
remember how earlier I told you gotta
have a clear set of outcomes the purpose
of this meeting that you're hoping for
this time here remember that one the
same way you gotta have a clear outcome
coming in you've got to have a very
specific call to action leaving the
meeting it could be unify here's what
we're doing we're on the same page these
are the six things we're going to be
focused on and here's the three numbers
we're gonna go hit let's go get them so
it's got to be clear call-to-action
leaving the event so once you're done
watching this video there's another
video I want you to watch because I want
you to be thinking about what things you
need to improve before you go to your
strategy session that you hold once
you're in that video is called how to
improve your sales process and increase
business the video should be right here
click on this link go watch our video
next take everybody bye-bye